yesterday i had the privilege of
debating the future of conservatism in
washington dc with a panel of seriously
brilliant intellectuals brought together
by the intercollegiate studies institute
these scholars
represented the various factions of the
conservative movement and they shed a
great deal of light on the problems
facing our nation i felt really
privileged to to even get to join them
and every single person on that panel
just got shown up by the most important
political philosopher of the week
nicki minaj
you can't speak
for the fear of the mob attacking you
if that doesn't give you chills up and
down your f spine
this is scary
you can't just innocently ask a question
about something going in your body
i remember going
to china and they were telling us you
know be you cannot speak out against
um you know
the the people in power there etc
and i remember all of us thinking okay
well you know we understand and we
respect the the laws here and and you
know that it's so different where we
live
but don't y'all see what's
happening
don't y'all see that
we are living now in that time
people will isolate you if you simply
speak and ask a question
i couldn't have said it better myself if
nikki thinks the u.s looks like chyna
now just wait until she finds out that
joe biden is attempting to deny medical
treatment to his political rivals i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from old schooled who
says trusting the mail-in voting system
is like asking a criminal to take your
paycheck to the bank that is absolutely
right in some cases it is literally
asking criminals to take
your uh your messages to the places that
they're supposed to go because a lot of
the people who are involved in vote
voter harvesting and the like are
criminal type of people it's hard
to sleep easy at night when you think of
all the crazy problems in our country
one way to make it easier to sleep easy
go check out my pillow you know that i
love the my pillow company they are a
great conservative patriotic company wow
i would still shop from them if they
were run by the taliban i would i would
because as much as i love their politics
and i love what they do
the real reason i shop there is the
product they just make the best products
they've got the best pillow i've ever
used they've got these amazing sheets
and now they've got the new my slippers
my pillow has taken over two years to
develop these wonderful slippers they're
designed to wear indoor outdoor all day
long
made with my pillow foam and impact gel
to help prevent fatigue
always made with quality leather suede
my wife i love her
but sometimes she takes my
mind pillow products she does she did it
with the
pillow she obviously we shared the same
bed with the sheets
she did it with the slippers get your
slippers today my pillow is offering 50
off the new my slippers go to
mypillow.com click on the radio
listeners square use promo code
dailywire at checkout recall 800 651
1148 you can also get deep discounts on
all my pillow products including the
geese of dream bed sheets of my pillow
mattress stopper my pillow towel sets
and more go to mypillow.com promo code
daily wire or call 1-800-651-1148
tell them that we sent you
1-800-651-1148
these deals will not last forever so
call now
joe biden
is now
promising i won't say threatening he's
promising to cut off medical supplies
potentially life-saving medical supplies
to his political opponents
so
joe biden even though the entire focus
of the public health
apparatus and the liberal establishment
has been on vaccines and we always need
vaccines they did the same thing during
aids we've got to focus all the energy
and money on vaccines not on
therapeutics to actually treat the
problem and
actually
much like with aids the vaccines have
had dubious effect we still don't have
an aids vaccine the reason that people
can survive aids now is because of
therapeutics well same thing with
coronavirus here the vaccines are less
effective than we were told they were
going to be and so now people are
turning to therapeutics but the biden
administration is saying he's going to
cut supplies to red states gensake was
just asked about this and the white
house doubled down he promised on
september 9th that he was going to send
50 more supply of monoclonal antibodies
to states
yet the binding administration is
cutting supplies in red states by 50 50
why is the biden administration cutting
these supplies
that's not accurate so let me give you
the accurate information uh first of all
we are increasing our distribution this
month by 50
over the last month though uh and one
thing that i think people need to
understand for clarity facts i know i
know you're like facts um is that
monoclonal antibodies are life-saving
therapies that are used after infection
to prevent more severe outcomes so
clearly the way to protect people and
save more lives is to get them
vaccinated but over the last month given
the rising cases due to the delta
variant and the lower number of
vaccination rates in some of these
states like florida like texas just
seven states are making up 70
of the orders our supply is not
unlimited and we believe it should be
equitable across states across the
country we believe it should be
equitable and that is why we're going to
cut the supplies to the states that need
it and we're going to
give the supplies to other states and
we're going to do so very often on the
basis
of political affiliation notice though
what that reporter asks there she says
why are you cut you're cutting the
supplies on the basis of vaccination
rates but many of the people who need
them are already vaccinated so they
actually did everything that you're
telling them to do and you're still
cutting the supplies to them and by the
way
even though jen saki and the white house
and the public health establishment are
still harping on the vaccine don't
forget that the vaccine has not
been the bulletproof protection that
that we were told it was there's a
headline now i know we're not allowed to
report on this but here it's from npr
it's from a left-wing news source fact
checkers so please please spare me
highly vaccinated israel is seeing a
dramatic surge in new covid cases here's
why and then they try to explain it away
israel is
the most vaccinated place on earth
triple vaccinated in many cases and they
are having a huge spike in covet cases
well here's why the immunity from the
vaccine dips over time and the delta
variant broke through the vaccine's
protection and and israel's high
vaccination rate is still not enough
even though it's more than basically
anywhere else on earth and vaccines are
key but you know you need to do more
stuff than that and booster shots are
great and you got to get the booster
shots and excuse after excuse after
excuse
it's that it didn't work
it didn't work
like you all told us it would your
predictions
on the efficacy of the vaccines much
like your predictions on every other
aspect of the virus going back to 15
days to slow the spread were wrong and
so people don't trust you any more
public health experts and it's not our
fault that we don't trust you it's your
fault that we don't trust you
so now the effect of this is okay now
that
people for whatever reason are still
getting covered at this high rate
we're going to cut the supplies marco
rubio just came out he said stop
rationing treatment
every day it's something new with these
people in the binding administration and
they literally want to punish and
control everybody that doesn't do what
they want them to do here's the latest
all right do you know how many people i
know including vaccinated people that
got covered and were able to get an
antibody treatment and as a result of
the antibody treatment it kept them from
getting really sick they kept them from
out of the hospital in some cases i
believe and i think their doctors
believe it may have saved their lives
i personally know dozens of people that
have gone through that including family
members that went through that now the
biden administration because they don't
like the way florida is handling
vaccines and not forcing people to do it
in states like florida as well
now they've decided they're going to
ration the antibody treatments they're
going to start rationing it there's not
a shortage there isn't some crisis but
they've decided they want to start
rationing it this reeks of politics this
is ridiculous this is outrageous people
see it for what it is these people are
completely out of control i don't know
what we can do about it in congress but
i'm going to start looking at it because
this stuff needs to stop these people
are bordering now on tyranny and it's
outrageous it has to stop
so rubio's diagnosis here is totally
right the prescription
he admits he says i have no idea what
we're going to do about it
but the diagnosis is right
the left
is
depriving their political opponents
of medicine
that's what it boils down to
this is not medically justified it's not
scientifically justified it's not as
much as gensake wants to spin it you
can't really make a case for this other
than pure revenge and the dehumanization
of your political opponents which we saw
just the other night from don lemon on
cnn i think if you want to understand
why joe biden is doing what he's doing
listen to the way that cnn is talking
about these same people
i think we have to stop coddling people
when it comes to this and the vaccine
saying oh you can't shame them you can't
call them stupid you can't call them
silly again yes they are the people who
ate and abetted trump are stupid because
they believed his big lie
the people who are not getting vaccines
who are believing the lies on the
internet instead of science it's time to
start shaming them what else or leave
them behind
because they are keeping the majority of
americans behind
you didn't feel that way about the polio
vaccine you don't feel that way about
measles mumps rubella when it comes to
your children all of a sudden this
vaccine is different
what's different about it the only
different thing about it is because of
your politics today the the people
talking about well i don't know what's
in the shot chris i don't know what's in
that shot
i'll tell you what's not in it hold on a
tracking device yeah let me let me let
me finish this
you know what's that you know what they
they get shots in
nowadays and they're rear ends
they're getting shots to make it bigger
okay so there's no reason to go go on
listening to a tweedledee and tweedledum
here not a whole lot going on between
don lemon's ears so he said a lot of
things that are not true for instance
the suggestion that covet and polio are
the same thing they're not one one will
will attack children
specifically will [ __ ] you one is a
really big problem and the other is a is
a cough that for the vast majority of
people is not not a huge deal uh what is
the difference between the vaccines well
one is a vaccine we've had for a very
very very long time the other is a
vaccine that was hastily developed and
until very recently did not have
fda approval
so there are big differences here but i
don't who cares i'm not even focused on
that what i'm focused on is that first
part
they're stupid
they need to be shamed they need to be
left behind this is just the latest
iteration of they're deplorable they're
irredeemable they're bitter clean they
don't
like you they don't want you to have
political rights they don't want you to
be part of the country and now they're
willing to deprive you
of medical treatment
that
is some seriously dangerous stuff
that to quote nicki minaj this is like
china oh my gosh oh my gosh this is like
china it is you don't know the half of
it honey it is i'm we listen to nikki
listen don't listen to the squishes
listen
to nikki when you want to protect
your
your life in your digital sense when you
want to protect your life as a matter of
your identity i would strongly recommend
you check out lifelock researchers have
determined that email phishing attacks
and brute force attacks are the two most
popular and successful methods cyber
criminals use for ransomware and
extortion attacks on corporate networks
these attacks are simple to attempt
difficult to detect and can come with
big rewards for cyber criminals
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet all of us do that in an
instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances and your
credit well good thing there's lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats like for instance your
social security number for sale on the
dark web now i know what you're thinking
but michael no one's after my data yes
they are no but michael they're only
after the famous people's data and
they're powerful people and that no
they're after yours okay
protect yourself no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton join now save up to 25 off your
first year by going to lifelock.com
knowles that's lifelock.com
knowles for 25 off
speaking of cancel culture
both the cancel culture that nicki minaj
is decrying and the cancel culture that
you're hearing from don lemon and the
like of and joe biden you know denying
people medical treatment
a math teacher in missouri just got
fired the math teacher got fired for
posting her views on facebook
this is a tale that we've heard many
many times in recent years so beth reems
who spent 25 years as an
employee at pembroke high school in
kansas city missouri
was the facilitator for the school's
popular conservative club
and she says she avoided politics in her
math classroom she saw no use for it
but she did use her private facebook
page to express her political views
and the problem with facebook is that
even the private pages are not so
private
what you put out there on social media
will be seen by people
so she's she made perfectly innocuous
points she she posted
it's racist to think only white people
can be racist
obviously that's true
she one time she posted a picture of al
sharpton one of the most notorious race
hustlers in the country and said good
morning america what are we offended by
today it's just these very funny frankly
milk toast sort of posts
this missouri prep school has now
fired her
now i think there are three ways to
react to this
three way there's the the lib way to
react which is good she should be fired
she's not an anti-racist she's a white
supremacist whatever kind of silly
things they're gonna say right that's
the celebration of her being fired
then
there is the
sort of moderate
way the maybe call it libertarian or
something way to react which is
this is terrible this is cancel culture
no one should ever be fired for posting
their political views
but that that reaction i think has a
problem which is what if what if
this woman had actually posted
bad things what if this woman had
actually posted you know swastikas and
said heil hitler
it's a political view
are you so you're saying she should be
fired for her political views but only
some political views but not these
political views but so that the neutral
libertarian say whatever you want
you i don't think that really works
then there is the conservative reaction
which is
this woman should not be fired
but her radical leftist colleagues
should
that's my that's my view if you post a
perfectly innocuous mainstream
conservative thing on facebook not only
should you not be fired for that but
your colleagues who post radical
left-wing things should be fired for
that sort of thing
at the very least
they should be fired if they bring these
sorts of views into the classroom right
maybe you say okay if it's on a facebook
page and really no one's it's kind of
public though because it's facebook but
and no one really sees it okay whatever
we're not gonna go you know interrogate
you for thought crimes but if you
express your radical leftist views in
the classroom you should be fired that's
the conservative view that's the only
coherent view the neutral view is
completely imaginary it's never existed
anywhere and the idea that a high school
classroom is a free marketplace of ideas
is preposterous as well the point of
schooling certainly elementary and
middle schools and i think high schools
too is indoctrination that is the point
you're supposed to learn things
not you're not just supposed to have a
free-flowing hippy-dippy exchange that
doesn't even really exist you will learn
certain things and so what are the
things that you're going to learn
what the left has done
is in the name of academic freedom
they've totally transformed what used to
be valuable serious education into
nonsense and this is one of the
paradoxes of education by the way
education is meant to make you a free
person that's that's what liberal
education that's why we call it that
it's meant to make you a free person but
in order to become a free person you
have to be coerced you have to learn
certain facts and if you get the
questions wrong on the test you get a
bad grade and you have to you actually
have to be
forced
to become educated to become free so
that you don't need to be forced anymore
and and somewhere along the line we
forgot that we got to go back to it one
thing you hear a lot about in classrooms
is a trigger warnings you know in recent
years this is the idea that before you
read any work that might in any way
offend your delicate sensibilities
you'll say trigger warning
this work contains violence
or sex or whatever and usually what this
is used for is just to
suppress
great works that contradict leftist
orthodoxy
so we've made that point for years
on the right and the left has ignored it
well now
there is a study there is a study that
shows that trigger warnings don't work
this is actually a study based on 17
other studies using a range of media
including literature passages
photographs and film clips
showing
that not only do trigger warnings
discourage people from reading and
viewing important works they actually do
discourage you from engaging in the
first place but they don't even do what
we're told they do namely
help people to avoid emotional trauma
the trigger warnings according to this
these these studies do not alleviate
emotional distress they do not
significantly reduce negative effect
or minimize intrusive thoughts
two hallmarks of ptsd
and uh these findings hold for
individuals with and without a history
of
trauma
like
all of these other
ways that the left has upended our
classrooms and upended our whole culture
they don't accomplish the thing that
they are supposedly supposed to
accomplish
what they actually accomplish
is giving the political order over to
the left and we've got to stop falling
for it and and
yet again in this case there are three
reactions you can have there's the lib
reaction of yeah we need trigger
warnings on everything that might be in
any way offensive and then there's the
kind of libertarian view which is well
you know if the teacher wants trigger
warnings that's fun leave it up to
the the teacher leave it up to the
classroom or leave it up to the school
and then there's the conservative view
get this out of here ban it don't permit
it it's bad it's harming students
education it's undermining the education
and if you undermine
liberal education then you are
undermining
your your own free country because the
whole point of it is to make free
citizens who are capable of free
societies and free government so if you
if you destroy the education you are
destroying free
society
speaking of
once free men now apparently becoming
captive i i have to talk about i meant
to get to this yesterday this time
magazine cover
uh it's a time magazine cover of
the world's most influential people and
on it it's it's harry and megan
and it's the saddest cover i
i have ever seen on a magazine it is
megan
standing there looking straight forward
she's in the front of the picture and
she's just looking right at you
and then it's harry kind of crouched
behind her hook grasping onto her like a
little marsupial in the back and he's
holding on to her but she's paying no
attention to him
men
do not do not let this become you this
is a cautionary tale
what is wrong with this photo some
people are saying well the photo michael
it just shows
a supportive husband with his wife
but michael he's just he's just caring
for his wife no i don't see support i
don't see a mutual
kind of bond of affection here i see a
woman who is in front leading the show
paying absolutely no attention to her
husband whatsoever and then a man who is
kind of clinging on to her like a little
pet
and
i i don't think this is
in any way helpful or supportive
the traditional view is that the husband
has some kind of a leadership role in
the household obviously that has been
inverted here and it's been inverted
just like all of the standards of
of our civilization have been inverted
in the middle and later part of the 20th
century largely by feminists actually
but when you think of good marriages do
you think that the
the markles are a good marriage mr and
mrs meghan markle do you think that
would be an example of a good marriage
is that the kind of marriage you want to
be in
a marriage where you've got this crazy
domineering narcissist ripping this man
away from his family from all of his
obligations
the clearest example of natural
obligations you would see the royal
family the whole point of the royal
family is to serve the country
and merely then to move to hollywood to
play pretend land to serve nothing but
themselves and their own vanity and
their narcissism and their pretend pleas
for privacy when all they ever seem to
do is go on television and go on
podcasts and go on on
magazine covers doesn't seem
like you want privacy all that much to
me and to serve their need for money
they want to make more and more money on
their own
does that seem like a good
marriage
it does not
and it is no coincidence that in this
marriage
you get that photo
a cautionary tale not not everything
uh
is is the way that it seems okay the the
supposed good guys
in our culture today
that the people who are on the right
side of history
they are the people who are just to give
a sort of random survey off the top of
my head who are on the side of
killing babies of denying medical
treatment to their political opponents
of subverting our elections of denying
the right of the people self-government
of destroying education of abusing
children actually in that case
they're on the side of this total
upending of things
doesn't seem like they're the good guys
do not whatever in the most subtle of
ways to quote to quote the crown
it is in the little things that the rot
begins do not let that happen to you
speaking of bad marriages
this is these are marriages that are
actually worse than the marcos somehow
incredibly
you know we have all the good guy afghan
refugees coming up it's all we didn't
get all the americans out of afghanistan
but we have all these afghan refugees
they helped us they were all translators
we somehow half that country was
translators and they're coming and
they're highly highly vetted even though
some people who had already been
deported from america were
now uh landing in afghanista landing at
dulles airport in america from
afghanistan but they had been deported
20 years ago and it seemed it's a little
that the official narrative seems a
little questionable we are now learning
that some of the
men the wonderful refugees that are here
are actually
child abusers they're they're men who
are arriving with child brides who now
have to be separated from their husbands
because it's not a proper marriage i
mean some of these girls are as young as
10 or 12 years old it would appear
this is not some random you know
conservative talking point that's based
on some conspiracy theory actually
our friend senator cruz just got
joe biden's secretary of state to admit
it
on august 27th according to public
reports you distributed internal
documentation highlighting numerous
instances in intake centers of sexual
abuse
in which much older grown afghan males
appeared with children young children
claimed they were their brides claimed
they were their wives
and the documents said the state
department urgently requested guidance
that was your word urgently
subsequently the department of homeland
security said that it showed the
desperation of families that they were
willing to give little girls to grown
men to be subject to sexual abuse and
child wives
my question is as follows did you
receive that urgent guidance
how many children have been subject to
sexual abuse what have you done
to rescue young children
from
illegal and abusive relationships
after being brought to america by the
state department there have been a to my
knowledge a limited number of cases
where we have separated people because
we were concerned uh that they were uh
how they are
the cases i'm aware of a handful just a
handful it's not a big those are the
ones that i'm aware of but the problem
is anthony blinken isn't aware of
anything and the other problem is
there's virtually no vetting going on i
actually just sat down with senator cruz
in dc a couple of days ago he just
traveled to fort bliss which is one of
the places where the
afghan refugees are being held
and what he was told by the people on
the ground there is
there's there's no vetting going on
anywhere
by the way when these refugees are being
held in places it's not as though
they're being held in prison
it's just open air they can they can
just leave if they want cruz said that
there was one refugee who just called an
uber
and who just left and and
so
when
the senator was speaking to some of the
officials there he said okay so how are
you processing these people how are you
you know going through going through and
making sure they are who they say they
are and what he was told by officials
there is oh no don't worry the vetting
took place in afghanistan but we what we
were told by the people who were
who were monitoring the evacuation out
of afghanistan is that the vetting
wasn't going on there as well i mean
there were people literally clinging to
the to the wheels of of airplanes people
just flooding on it was absolute chaos
so the long and short of it is
you've got people
who are now bringing their child brides
who are very very bad people who are now
flooding into the united states
meanwhile americans overseas left behind
now speaking of
different cultural perspectives on sex
it's a mild way to put child brides i
guess
the toy company lego
has a new set of toys out for kids it's
the queer eye toy
queer eye the fab five loft it's from
queer eye for the straight guy you
remember that show and it's all these
gay guys who are interior designers and
a very popular show
so some people are very upset by this
they say we shouldn't have
a show called the queer eye they
shouldn't have little toys for kids and
i don't know
i my problem is not with lego okay my
problem is not with the fact that this
this show that focuses on an aspect of
the sexual revolution was made into a
toy for kids
i think that's inevitable
i think that if you have a culture that
is really focused on sex sex of all
kinds
that even sort of an unusual sexual
desire would then be the kind of hook
for this very popular tv show that's
been on for many many years at this
point inevitably you're going to get
toys about that that's going to permeate
the whole culture
and there's no there's no way to
separate that i mean this is one of the
failures of the you do you idea of
society the libertarian i mean these are
the things we were debating yesterday in
dc and you can check out that panel at
the intercollegiate studies institute
is it just doesn't work because we
actually do live together in a polity in
a society and
my behavior actually will affect other
people the libs are kind of right about
this
and your behavior will affect me and the
prevailing standards and mores actually
will affect the kind of country that
we're going to have and it's going to
affect
the way that we individually develop as
well it's going to affect the way that
we raise our kids and so if you if you
have a problem with that then you need
to stand up and actually have the
cajones to say no we are not going to
tolerate certain shows on tv whether i
mean queer eye
seems kind of low on the priority list
of things that you've gotta gotta get
off tv but you're gonna say no we're not
gonna permit certain things in the
classroom no we're not you've got to
learn the magic word
no but unfortunately we got too many
squishes we just saw this with this
republican candidate for governor glenn
younkin in virginia he was asked to
debate his his opinion on the pro-life
law in
texas
and i think he gave the worst possible
answer
i think the texas bill is one that is
the standard right now that we're all
looking at and i would not sign the
texas bill today
as i've said through this entire
campaign i'm pro-life
i believe in exceptions in the case of
rape and incest and when the life of the
mother is in jeopardy
but the texas bill also
also was unworkable and confusing
what we're not doing this evening is
talking to my opponent about his extreme
views
see my opponent doesn't want to talk
about this topic tonight because
he actually called legislation that
would enable abortion paid for with
taxpayer money all the way up through
and including birth
where a child is kept comfortable while
decision is made where that child lives
or dies he called that legislation
common sense legislation and said he
would sign it
friends my opponent wants to be the
abortion governor and i want to be the
jobs government mr yonkin your time is
up
this was a bad answer he thought it was
such a clever answer it's a bad answer
and just learn this lesson folks what
what glenn young thought he was doing
here by by criticizing the texas law but
still saying i'm pro-life except for
some i'm willing to kill some babies but
not all babies and you know and and but
it's a bad law and i hate it i wouldn't
have it here but in my opponent then he
made one good move which is he said my
opponent's really radical on abortion
okay that's that's true
you know let's talk about abortion third
trimester abortions with that that
degenerate terry mcauliffe supports
but then he says he wants to be the
abortion governor i want to be the jobs
governor and it's just he thinks that
he's placating the pro-lifers and
delaying the fears of the pro-abortion
people in reality he's doing neither
he's he is
now losing the trust of conservatives
who thinks he's going to go squish on a
very important issue and he's not
picking up a single lib vote not one lib
was convinced by his answer
who who previously was going to vote
against him was was convinced to vote
for him it just
it was too clever by half politicians do
this a lot
do nuts now is not the time to squish
now is the time for leadership and we're
in a moment of real political
realignment i think nicki minaj is
actually
showing that and so so now is the time
to actually people want to follow
leaders they don't want to follow
squishes who are trying to sneak into a
job by
ignoring very important political issues
and just saying i'll get you better jobs
speaking of
jobs
the federal government does not want us
to continue to do business because we
are not going to force our employees to
shoot themselves up with this
experimental drug and so they're going
to try to come after us and they're
going to threaten us with major fines
and
we're not going to comply with biden's
stupid mandate so if you want to help
support us head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off we'll be right back
with the mailbag
it is my favorite time of the week when
i get to hear from you in the mail bag
first question up is from
elise oh it's sort of like sweet little
elisa from elise hey michael i'm a
single woman in my 20s and i have a
dating question dating is not super fun
for me and i have a lot of anxiety about
it when i actually like someone i get in
my head and overthink everything which
makes me act not like myself and i feel
like it messes things up what are your
thoughts on
how not how to be confident just being
myself or on how to be confident just
being myself and not overthinking too
much about the outcome sincerely
sometimes i think i think too much this
happens to a lot of people usually it's
men who complain about this but but it
can happen to women too i for one
actually find it kind of charming
if if
back in my single days if i'm talking to
a woman and she gets a little bit
nervous or blushes or something i i
really like that i think that that is
sort of evidence that she likes me you
know and and vice versa i don't think
that's necessarily the worst thing in
the world especially
when a woman does it because you know
the
the man because he is the one pursuing
the woman he's the one asking her out he
i think needs to appear more confident
but if the woman you know
demonstrates her affection or kind of
gives in a little bit i actually think
that's that's sort of charming but but
if you
want to
seem a little more confident just uh
keep in mind this one in the
individual interactions very likely you
are the one being pursued
very likely it's not you doing the
pursuingness so you might be putting
yourself out there but but it's very you
know just as a matter of the sexes
usually it is the men who are pursuing
the women and so you're already in the
position of power
right you are you are already the one
who can say yes i want to get a drink
with you or no i don't want to get a
drink with you
and uh beyond that
how does a gosh i get it's a little
trickier i can tell a man how to have
confidence but how does the woman have
confidence i guess
consciousness is
one of the ways that a woman can have
confidence
just remember that every insecurity that
you have you feel that you're whatever
your body doesn't look good or you're uh
you know you're a little too weird or
you're
i don't know
women have all sorts of insecurities
even more than men do
just remember that every other woman in
human history has had all of those
insecurities and and just just be cool
about it just recognize hey i am no
different in this regard than any other
woman who has ever lived and so yes
maybe i'm feeling anxious yes maybe i'm
feeling nerves yes maybe i'm feeling
butterflies every other woman has as
well
from anthony hello mr knowles during the
latest backstage episode jeremy
mentioned how protestantism was in
decline in america while catholicism was
in the ascendant do you agree that the
catholic church is ascendant as someone
who attends a traditional latin mass i
do see the growing side of the church
however with pachamama cardinal
mccarrick the pope's suppression of the
latin mass liturgical abuse scandal it
seems that the one true church has its
fair share of issues issues which hold
it back from having the real cultural
influence at once enjoyed love the show
and appreciate all you do yes the
catholic church has a ton of problems
hillary bellock famously said
he said i have to take it as a matter of
faith that the catholic church is
divinely instituted but for
non-believers proof of that divine
institution is that no other institution
conducted which with such navish
imbecility would have lasted a fortnight
so this has been a long-standing issue
in the church and in recent years it's
gotten worse than it has been in the
past
that's actually not the point that
jeremy was making as i understood it and
it's it's not the point that i think is
pretty good
jeremy is observing that many of the
people who are leading
the new
right you know who are really in the
ascendant in their influence in in the
conservative movement in america
patrick dineen so rob amari adrian
vermeule a number of other people
are catholic and jeremy thinks this is
kind of weird because america we are
told is a protestant country and this is
maybe because the mainline protestant
churches have collapsed i think that's
true this is maybe because the
evangelical churches have become
shockingly left-wing in just the last
few years i mean really george floyd was
one of the
moments that really brought a lot of
evangelical churches to the left and a
lot of my evangelical friends have
complained about that sure
that that too
but i think what jeremy is failing to
appreciate is a is a little secret about
conservatism in america which is that it
has always been led by catholics
which is really weird because it america
does seem like a protestant country and
yet you go back even not that far but
you go back to the origin of the modern
conservative movement who do you have
bill buckley catholic brent bozell
catholic phyllis schlafly catholic
james burnham even catholic uh frank
meyer invented fusionism catholic
the list goes on russell kirk oh my gosh
one of the most important conservatives
catholic and if they didn't all start
out catholic they became catholic over
time why i'm not going to make any
religious point
exactly for you know about the religious
truth of catholicism i'm just going to
point out that catholicism is an
incarnational faith so it's a faith that
says it doesn't matter if you just think
about things all the time you actually
have to do it you have to do the
sacraments you have to receive the
literal body and blood of christ you
actually you got to put it in your body
it's a real thing with a real pope who
wears a real hat and that that is just a
different approach
than
uh more rationalistic approaches to uh
to
religion and ultimately to politics and
so
there is a reason that the catholic
church is one of if not the only
institution that survived from antiquity
through modernity it's because it
partakes of that
real thing
the understanding that what happens in
time and space actually does
matter and i think that's a deeply
conservative view so even beyond the
questions of you know what what church
you go to on sunday i think
the
the catholic view of the whole wide
world and the catholic view of politics
is just naturally going to lend itself
to conservatism and it's why the most
effective conservatives in america
even in a protestant country have been
catholic from emma dear michael i come
to you from a difficult spot i'll get
right to it my husband wants a threesome
but i'm not so into the idea personally
i hate the idea of seeing him with
another woman he's offered bringing
another man into the mix instead but
then i can't understand why he would be
okay seeing me with another man he says
he wouldn't be jealous because it's
about pleasing me but i don't think i'd
enjoy it i love my husband but don't
know what to do any insight would be
appreciated sincerely three's a crowd
yeah your husband is acting like a
degenerate and you should tell him that
and uh just be very blunt with him and
you know look people do all sorts of
curious kooky things in in the bedroom
especially these days because it's much
more socially acceptable
what you said there i think highlights
the problem is that one line you said
when you said to your husband hey why do
you want to watch some
other dude stop your wife and and he
said well because
i wouldn't be jealous it's about
pleasing you it's not about pleasing you
it's not
marriage is not just about
you and he each receiving more and more
pleasure for yourself
sex is not just about you getting
pleasure and feeling good
there's an aspect of that but really
what it is about is the union of two
people there is a unitive and
dare i suggest it procreative aspect of
that it's actually not primarily about
you it's primarily about the other
person to whom you have
vowed to be loyal and faithful for your
life vowed before god himself and before
the community so it's a political act as
well
something tells me your husband has just
gone down some
you know not so healthy roads maybe in
his thoughts maybe he's looking at
naughty things on the computer i hope
he's not cheating on you but whatever it
is look
this this
happens to men i think much more than it
happens to women and you know men have
certain instincts that can be either
suppressed or exacerbated they can be
suppressed by practicing virtue and they
can be exacerbated by giving in to vice
and the more you do either of those
things the more of it you're going to
get so what i would recommend if you
think your husband as i do is acting
like a
degenerate and a derelict uh
you should say okay buddy
stop thinking those thoughts whenever
you start thinking those thoughts think
of something think of baseball
think of grandma whatever think of it
get some anything to get your mind way
off those thoughts uh if he's looking at
porn which i bet he is tell him just cut
it out and you know tell him that he
needs to put
filters or whatever you know so there is
software i think that you can put on
your computer to so that that doesn't
happen just tell them to work on it
because
he has these desires now
presumably because he has stoked them
you sometimes hear this that that human
beings have two wolves in them
the bad wolf and the good wolf
the bad the bad guy part and the good
guy part well which wolf is it controls
who you are whichever one you feed is
the answer and so you can create these
really bad pathways in your brain you
can really exacerbate these disordered
desires and
it's going to be difficult to stop that
but the way to stop that is to stop
feeding that bad wolf okay and then over
time the the
better desires will become the more
dominant ones best of luck don't have a
threesome from brandon hey michael i'm a
member of the us army and as you know
we've been hit with massive vaccine
mandates i've requested religious
exemption from the vaccine for two
reasons one i don't think it would be
morally right to benefit from a vaccine
that was developed at the expense of the
lives of unborn children
two i believe that specifically the
nucleic acid technology used in the j j
moderna and bio and tech i don't even
know about that one vaccines are not in
line with christianity since these
vaccines would change the creation of
god at a fundamental cellular level and
even potentially genetic level
what are your thoughts thank you and
sincerely a concerned soldier yeah i
mean you know i strongly oppose the
vaccine mandates
i think it's awful
i think you should try to if you don't
want to get look if if you want to get
the vaccine i can see a bioethical
argument to do it but
as i've said from the very beginning i
think this is a prudential matter that
that really you should have much more
control over than say joe biden does or
your commanding officer does the problem
is that a lot of religious institutions
up to and including the catholic church
are not giving religious exemptions the
bishops have said it is permissible to
get the vaccine and some have even gone
further than that
so if you if you're catholic for
instance you're probably not going to
get one you might be able to get a
medical exemption if you find the right
doctor
and now if you're a member of some other
you know religion
you might be able to get a religious
exemption but my only caution to you
here is it's very
hard to get them i've talked to friends
of mine who are in the military who are
not having any luck getting them so
this is a
as as the vaccine should have been from
the beginning
the way to avoid getting the vaccine is
a prudential matter to you but i think
that
most options are on the table
from nick hi michael oh no oh no
me again uh-huh this has been a while
since well let's
why do we take questions from nick i
the for those who are just tuning in and
are not aware nick
has assuming it's the same nick nick has
had some of the most colorful questions
in the history of my show all right
let's get on with it since breaking up
with my above average girlfriend last
month i've enjoyed living my life like a
phoenix rising from the ashes however
rather than diving in the sea of babes
i've tried to be more productive with my
viagra level sex drive
and focus my testosterone on combat
sports training that's actually i'm
that's good i'm glad to hear that i
joined an mma gym and quickly became the
gladiator level stud at the gym and
loved sparring and wrestling around the
mats with these dudes no homo
my question is when is it morally
appropriate to use these new deadly
weapons my fists feet and perfectly
formed
biceps on someone
i am borderline ready to walk the
streets at night hoping to find someone
littering that i can take to pound town
no homo
p.s do i want to read this psps i took
your advice and threw a stick outside my
office hoping that it would land near
someone that i could marry it's a long
story so i'll just say doug in
accounting might be a tad bit
homo
nick nick nick
what would be a positive
i don't want to just
criticize you because i actually think
you've made some improvements since
you've been writing about your derelict
relationship with women i think it is
good
that you're channeling your obviously
above average levels of virility and
energy
toward improving yourself and in this
case your physicality and not toward
leading women astray that's that's good
um
as to your question when should you
go out looking for a fight you should
never go out looking for a fight it's a
bad idea do not that is now another
thing that you have to resist
don't take your guns to town bill leave
your guns at home jim don't take your
guns to town
we have a
law enforcement apparatus in this
country to deal with criminals just so
that you do not become a vigilante this
is a very bad thing defend yourself when
you've got to defend yourself you
obviously have a right to do that and
you have really i think an obligation to
do that but and certainly to defend
innocent people
but you do not have the right and the
authority to go out and take anybody to
pound town just because you want to
swing your deadly weapons i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
i'll see you next week
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin